blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman well it has happened we have been
waiting for some
signal and we've been talking about it
all week and
last week what is the future of the
republican party in the united states
republicans have now canceled one of
their own
liz cheney republican congresswoman from
wyoming
republicans have voted and she is out
from leadership and this is seen widely
as a signal
that the trumpian wing of the republican
party
is here at least through 2022 and
depending on what happens in 2022
it may persist beyond that or it may not
uh and we are going to have all of the
different details
understand that the context here is
republicans claim to be against cancel
culture
and yet this movement to cancel one of
their own
republican congresswoman liz cheney is
predicated on the fact
that she admits accepts realizes use
whatever word you want
that donald trump lost the 2020 election
that's what this is fundamentally about
and house republicans
have voted to remove her
from her leadership role believed that
she will be replaced
by pro-trump congresswoman elise
stefanik that news
we may know that for sure by the time
today's program is published we're
recording it while a lot of this
news is breaking but the no confidence
vote was expected today for liz cheney
and it took place during a closed-door
republican conference meeting
and uh we know that this is the
anti-cancel
party canceling one of their own for
what really
should be a very uncontroversial it's
not even a view
i i struggle to even say it's her view
she simply
accepts the facts it's like saying we've
canceled someone because of their
opinion on gravity
like well no i mean someone you can
either accept
how gravity works or you cannot accept
it but it doesn't change the reality
that's fundamentally what we're talking
about here
liz cheney has criticized donald trump
for spreading the lie
that the 2020 election was rigged
against him it was not
uh and republicans are furious and
they've wanted her demoted for some
period of weeks now arguably this
movement has been
building for several months and they
would love for her to lose her seat
altogether
although from what i've recently heard
she does plan to run for re-election
in 2022 check out how some republicans
are framing this
here is republican congressman jim
jordan
saying liz cheney defending free and
fair elections that's essentially what
she did last night on the floor of the
house
conceding that they lost those are
called
democrat talking points according to
congressman jim jordan this is from
laura ingram's program on fox news last
night committee congressman your
thoughts on what you just heard from liz
cheney
you can't have the republican conference
chair reciting democrat
talking points especially when gas
prices are up 50
there's a crisis on the border and
democrats are trying to federalize
election law and pack the united states
supreme court
that is not helpful that is the concern
and that's why three months ago
there were a number of us who wanted to
make a change that change in fact
will happen tomorrow laura and i think
that's a good thing for our party
you want our party spokesperson to be in
tune with more than a
single digit percentage of the party now
of course the things
that jim jordan cites there are all
bogus and we've talked about most of
them individually already gas prices are
up for two reasons
number one the resurgence of demand as
we come out of the pandemic there was a
demand collapse last year
now demand is recovering and number two
there's this pipeline problem
that is both temporary but has nothing
whatsoever to do with joe biden so jim
jordan's just making stuff up it has
nothing to do with any of this they're
just canceling someone that's all that's
going on
uh the crisis at the border you we can
we can fine-tune to what degree there is
a problem at the border and there is one
uh but the sudden biden crisis has been
something ginned up by republicans
who didn't care about the situation at
the border when it was under
donald trump and it's all made up but
the real story here
is they say don't cancel people for
dissenting views
we don't cancel people for dissenting
views and here is a dissenting view
which is as uncontroversial as they come
the election result is real that's the
view and
liz cheney has been canceled here's one
other example
uh donald trump's daughter-in-law lara
lara trump
uh this morning on fox and friends
saying liz cheney needs to go
because her view that biden won
doesn't represent what most of
republicans believe and lara trump is
right about that most republicans have
fallen for this take a look
yeah well she really doesn't represent i
think the views of most republicans out
there
the the views of our party look there
are 75 million americans out there
that voted for president donald trump
that still have a lot of questions
about this election we can't just let it
go we can't just sweep it under the rug
and so whenever you stop representing
the party that
you know when you're the again the third
in leadership
there you really probably shouldn't have
a leadership role so we'll see
obviously what happens i know they're
going to vote on it but i think elise
stefanik would be incredible
she's been a great supporter of
republican and conservative values a
great supporter of my father-in-law
so i'd be happy to see her take that
position this
is really an issue of accepting reality
that's really what we're talking about
here it's it's it's becoming almost more
like a mental health issue than a
political issue it's a sort of psychosis
that has taken hold and without praising
liz cheney right i mean liz cheney is
not a friend of the left she's not a
progressive i probably agree with her
on essentially nothing but agreeing with
her that trump lost is sort of like
agreeing that
uh we breathe uh air of which oxygen is
a component right i mean it's not even a
political thing
what does lara trump know about anything
she's a commentator because her husband
is the son of a former president what
exactly are her credentials
but she's right that most republicans
seem unable to accept that donald trump
simply lost so on this one issue
liz cheney is correct she said last
night in a speech on the floor of the
house
that donald trump is a threat to america
that's true she said joe biden won
that's true she said the election is
over that the rule of law and the
constitutional process have taken hold
all of that is true
these are uncontroversial things and liz
cheney
is being punished for them this is how
backwards
the republican party is right now and as
they
have removed her from her party
leadership role today
um the republican party is committing in
a sense
to the opposite of what they claim to be
about but more importantly
we've been wondering is 2022 going to be
a continued trumpian republican year or
not
the answer appears to be that yes it
will many republicans
are uh not pleased with this from
outside
of the house of representatives and
that's exactly what i want to talk about
next
the new york times is a very interesting
report about
more than 100 republicans including
former republican
officials who are seriously looking at
abandoning the republican party and
starting their own third party
there's a great article by zach montague
published late yesterday i believe in
the new york times where he says
more than 100 republicans including some
former elected officials are preparing
to release a letter this week
threatening to form a third party
if the gop doesn't make certain changes
the statement is going to take aim at
former president trump's stranglehold on
republicans the timing of this
could not be uh more uh relevant
given that with the ouster of liz cheney
republican congresswoman from leadership
republicans in the house seem to be
committing
to a trumpian 2022 platform
the preamble to this letter says quote
when in our democratic republic forces
of conspiracy
division and despotism arise it is the
patriotic duty of citizens to act
collectively
in defense of liberty and justice and uh
this is a first step says miles taylor
who's an organizer of the effort if you
recognize that name that's because
taylor
is the former trump era department of
homeland security official who
anonymously wrote that book
condemning the trump administration he
has since acknowledged that
what was originally written anonymously
was written by him
he goes on to say quote this is us
saying that a group of more than 100
prominent republicans think that the
situation has gotten so dire with the
republican party
that it is now time to seriously
consider whether an alternative might be
the only option now we don't yet know
the full scope of who else is signing
this letter
at some point we will when the letter is
released i am not optimistic
that this group of hundred republicans
can actually
make a dent in the pro-trump
republican party of right now and here's
what i mean by that
we've looked at polling that tells us
the voters right now
are basically with trump 70 of them
still believe that donald trump
won something like two-thirds said
they would leave the republican party
and follow trump
if trump were to start his own party now
i don't think two-thirds really would
two-thirds are saying that they would
some wouldn't because they would realize
actually
you know maybe i don't want to follow
trump part of that two-thirds wouldn't
just because of laziness it actually
takes some effort to leave the
republican party
some would leave the republican party
and follow trump but would still mostly
vote for republicans so you know we have
to understand that that two-thirds is
not
if trump leaves republicans really lose
two-thirds of their votes
but although trump seems to have met
millions and tens of millions of
republicans that would follow him out
it's not clear to me that if a hundred
republican officials leave the party
that that many voters follow them i
think that whatever
happens with the republican party in
2022 and 2024
is going to happen from within the
republican party
unless it's trump who bails if you
disagree with me i would love to hear
from you i just don't see any
serious willingness from republican
voters to say
particularly because they're mostly with
trump
if some officials leave i will go with
them
the counterpoint to this is that not
that many have to leave
in order to potentially completely
sabotage the chances of republicans in
2022.
many of these 2022 races are going to be
very tight
particularly in the senate but in the
house as well
and even if it's true that 70 75 80
of republicans would not even consider
leaving just because
miles taylor is starting some third
party
and i think that that's the case if only
a few of them do
leave and they are disproportionately
voting republicans because remember
particularly in midterms
sometimes half or more of the country
doesn't even vote it doesn't take
that much to potentially completely
upend the chances of republicans at
taking back the house
or the senate in 2022. so we have to
sort of hold both things on the one hand
it is very clear that it's trump who
holds the cards here trump is still
fundraising
uh trump is recreating his
communications with the party
although to a very limited degree of
success those blog posts he's making are
only getting a couple hundred thousand
views
total um and it is still a republican
party
in the house of representatives in the
senate that privately many of them
despise me privately maybe many of them
despise trump
or don't like the direction he's taking
the party or whatever but
they clearly have calculated if and
until it becomes clear that the voters
are no longer with trump
i need to stay with trump publicly for
self-preservation
to avoid getting the the trump dagger of
saying that person needs to be voted out
or whatever the case may be
so good for these republican officials i
don't think this is going to have much
of an impact whatsoever i'd love to hear
from you about it you can find me on
twitter
at d pacman and remember that monday
memorial day that's not this coming
monday
it's not the next one i believe it's the
one after that monday the 31st
we are doing a one-day membership
special if you would like to be
notified about this membership special
and it is a beauty
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video remember
that every day
there's really two shows there's this
show
and then there's the bonus show you can
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpackman.com it doesn't have to be
just the podcast every day we've got
that bonus show
and you can use the coupon code better21
to get a discount if you so please
at joinpacman.com we appear
really genuinely to be getting to the
later phases of fighting the coronavirus
pandemic even with the anti-vac
sentiment that is plaguing much of the
country which we've talked about
we are continuing to get more and more
good news
about the next few months in terms of
the battle against the pandemic
yesterday we received really great news
that the pfizer vaccine has been
approved for emergency use for 12 to 15
year olds this will allow
middle school age students to be fully
vaccinated by the time school starts in
the fall
we're going to talk more about that
approval a little bit later on in the
program but the pfizer vaccine has been
found to be 100
effective in a clinical trial of more
than 2
000 adolescents uh in terms of
protection and creating a robust
antibody response that's very very good
news
we also learned that even with the
current variants of concern
which include the british variant the
south african the brazilian the
california
the new york and the indian variants
we will likely not need a booster for
the pfizer vaccine in the next 6 to 12
months
and since the moderna and pfizer
vaccines work essentially identically
they're essentially clones
we will probably not need a moderna
booster
either in the next 6 to 12 months now
this is important to understand the
vaccines
will be updated over the next six to 12
months
to to account for the new variants at
some point in the future
a booster for already vaccinated people
may be needed but it appears that
already vaccinated people will not need
a tweaked booster in the next six to 12
months
people vaccinated for the first time in
the next six to 12 months
will start getting a tweaked version
that accounts for the variance
that's fantastic news but then maybe
as importantly as we've expected based
on the vaccination data
cases and deaths are continuing down and
that should accelerate as we approach
40 percent fully vaccinated in the u.s
and then
hopefully on to 50 recall that cases
peaked
at about 255 000 cases per day in
january i mean just
remember when we were saying if we're
not careful we might one day see a
hundred thousand cases a day well we got
to two and a half times that 255
000 cases per day in january we're down
about 85 percent from that level
to about 40 000 cases per day still a
lot
but that rate of decline is once again
accelerating by memorial day
it should be quite a bit below that and
we've even had a couple of days in the
last week
at the sort of 26 28 000 cases per day
level that's a good sign in terms of
deaths
recall that the pandemic high of more
than 3 400 deaths per day
uh was in late january that number
is now also down about 81 percent from
its peak
still 650 deaths per day still a tragedy
still a pandemic still much work to be
done but going in the right direction
and on a slight delay from the case
decline
we're seeing another inflection point
where we are seeing
faster decline in deaths down even to
the 200
300 level a couple of days this week
some of the lowest numbers in a very
long time
some states like massachusetts recently
reporting a single day with
zero deaths for the first time in
basically since the beginning of the
pandemic
now another bit of good news from the
vaccination front
is that after nearly a month of
declining vaccinations
because as we said supply was starting
to exceed demand
most of those who really wanted to be
vaccinated
have been able to get vaccinated and we
had to start work on the vaccine
resistant well the average
daily vaccinations have again started to
go up
they bottomed out at about 1.9 million
doses a day we're back
up to 2.2 million doses a day and as i
mentioned earlier
pfizer has now been approved for
emergency use
for 12 to 15 year olds we'll talk about
that in a moment and hopefully that will
increase the numbers as well
more and more countries are opening for
travel
in-person school in the fall is looking
like close to an absolute certainty
with many schools requiring vaccination
for students to come back to campus but
that's just the united states
this is a global fight what is happening
globally
where vaccine access is still a major
problem so
the good news globally is that after
another new peak in cases global cases
are now starting to trend down again and
are down about
seven percent from that new peak
global deaths are also just starting to
tick down and even in
india which was experiencing i mean just
incredible tragedy for the last month
cases per day appear to have peaked
and have just slightly started to
decline
it is going to be a very long road for
india but you
always prefer to see cases going down
rather than up so that's the current
panorama
a couple of other small things we're
learning that
early caution about the protection of
vaccines was appropriate before we knew
do they reduce spread how effective are
they
but as more and more health experts
continue to look at the data
they are increasingly comfortable saying
listen when you're vaccinated
just about every activity is low risk
that doesn't mean stop following cdc
guidelines
about masking indoors about protecting
others all of this stuff
but personal risk is really really
low if you are vaccinated so nothing in
this world is zero
no doubt but very good vaccine news and
we'll see where we are next week as far
as the numbers are concerned
let's now talk about the expansion of
the pfizer vaccine
to 12 to 15 year olds so the fda
has now authorized for emergency use
while they are
still evaluating uh a full approval
of the pfizer covid19 vaccine
the pfizer coveted shot has been
approved under emergency use for 12 to
15 year olds remember that
uh jnj and moderna shots currently
approved 18 plus
pfizer was already 16 plus now it is 12
plus this is a great
bit of news because there are 17 million
12 to 15 year olds in the united states
that represents about
five six percent of the total population
and that is a significant chunk
particularly when we think about
students being back in school many
already
and almost a certainty that they will be
going back to school in person in the
fall
being able to uh make eligible
an additional five or six percent of the
total population is a really great thing
uh this has been widely tested uh we
know that the vaccine
is uh essentially 100 effective at
preventing serious disease and death in
12 to 15
year olds it triggers a robust antibody
response
and there's a recent survey from the
kaiser family foundation's vaccine
monitor
which found that many parents even those
who have themselves been vaccinated
are reluctant to vaccinate their
adolescent kids sort of in that 12 to 16
12 to 17 range it's really important
that that happens for several reasons
not the least of which
is that going back to school without
vaccinated kids
just doesn't pass the sniff test it just
doesn't make logical sense
and we are expecting vaccination for 12
to 15 year olds to start
this week appointments at least in some
states already being open to 12 to 15
year olds as soon as
as soon as tomorrow as soon as friday
and um
we are going to see uh likely as we saw
with the adult vaccination an initial
surge
and then probably a tapering off and
that's fine just
you know every time we get new
eligibility let's get as many people as
we can vaccinated and then over the
summer
as schools say in order to come back on
campus you're going to need a vaccine
um you're going to see more and more
people in that age range go and get that
vaccine
states counties and school districts
around the country
per the new york times are trying to
figure out the most reassuring
way uh to reach those younger
adolescents as well as their parents
in most states parents have to consent
to 12 to 15 year olds being vaccinated
um and so it will be not just the 12 to
15 year olds who need to want to get the
shot
it will also have to be the parents
which which makes sense
uh in most cases and there are plans to
offer the vaccines not only in schools
but also at pediatricians offices
day camps parks beaches and we're
increasingly hearing about
uh even some restaurants in some cases
getting involved
in the vaccine effort so uh you know
there's no question
i've been seeing on facebook anecdotally
people saying my kid is not getting any
shot
they're not getting anything
experimental there will be that there is
that in every single group
that's going to decline as 12 to 15 year
olds
start to get vaccinated and
overwhelmingly
start not to get the virus because the
vaccine works so well
certainly um schools requiring vaccines
for in-person
attendance are going to further increase
the number of parents who will say well
i wasn't big on it but
i've got to get these kids out of the
house i mean quite frankly it's sort of
a silly thing to say
to think about it in those terms but
that is going to be a factor as well
and uh there are going to be all sorts
of mobile vaccination initiatives
and uh plans to just make it as easy as
possible for 12 to 15 year olds to get
vaccinated so i continue to say
that by memorial day a lot of these
numbers are going to look significantly
better we expected them to start looking
better in mid-may and they
are we just went over that cases are now
down 84
deaths are now down 81 percent and
there is still you know i think there's
a couple things going on there's still
a lot of doom and gloomers who
are only focusing on the negatives and
there are negatives
650 deaths a day while down 81 percent
from the peak
is still a lot but in the more
vaccinated states you are starting to
see the daily deaths get down to
and even below the number of daily
deaths you typically see in a flu season
that is very good news and there is no
question at this point that we are able
to vaccinate our way out of this so
if you have kids in the 12 to 15 age
range
i would love to hear from you how are
you thinking of
this new emergency use approval on 12 to
15
if you are vaccinated but you don't plan
to have your kids get the vaccine
let me know why i'd be curious to hear
from you and we'll have more about the
vaccination effort on the show's
instagram page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show and make sure you're
following me on instagram as well at
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
we will talk about the latest covid lab
leak
conspiracies dr fauci was confronted by
rand paul
or maybe rand paul was confronted by dr
fauci i don't know exactly
we'll have to look at the video and
decide for ourselves that'll be after
this short
break and much more upcoming
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
so there was a senate hearing yesterday
involving a number of different public
health
officials the new cdc director rochelle
walensky participated and so did dr
anthony fauci the top infectious disease
doctor
in the united states and republican
senator rand paul was there
rand paul has been increasingly fixated
on a
coveted lab leak conspiracy
and this all came to a spectacular head
yesterday when rand paul
i guess confronted dr fauci about it and
dr
fauci reacted by saying quite plainly
rand paul has no idea what the hell he's
talking about and we're going to pick it
up near the start and dive into it
let's go right into the first clip think
about that for a moment
the sars virus had a 15 mortality
we're fighting a pandemic that has about
a one percent mortality can you imagine
if a sars virus that's been juiced up
and had viral proteins added to it to
the spike protein
if that were released accidentally
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect that the
nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research
in the wuhan institute do they find
doctors
we do not fund do you find dr barrick's
gain of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain or
function research and if it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted in north
carolina no i don't think it's
concerning a bad virus spike protein
okay so let's break down some of this
stuff it is
certainly possible that this wuhan
lab was researching coronaviruses
and even could have been researching
this specific coronavirus strain
in their lab and that should be looked
at
because it might have leaked in addition
to it already having been out in the
world
as an accident that's certainly possible
it should be
investigated what some people are going
to
is that this was a bioengineered weapon
amplified at the wuhan lab and released
into the public there is no evidence of
that whatsoever now
with all of these conspiracies one and
one can always say and conspiracists
typically do
you've not definitively proven that that
hasn't happened
but when you make the extraordinary
claim or when you make a claim
for which we have not seen evidence then
you should at least look for or present
some evidence if you want to be taken
seriously so this is like layer
one of the conspiracy which is
establishing as rand paul is trying to
do
that the nih and dr fauci himself in
some cases were
specifically funding research at the
wuhan lab but dr
fauci says we did not fund what is
called the gain
of function research if you don't know
what that term means
it's going to be hard to follow the rest
of this conversation
gain of function research is research
into making a microorganism
a virus etc have increased
transmissibility
increased virulence increased
immunogenicity
from what it has through a variety
of different processes processes that
can be done in a lab and dr
fauci simply says that wasn't being done
and we're not funding that and dr fauci
was ready for what followed from rand
paul here that he got from the wuhan
institute into the sars viruses gain of
function
that is not a minority because at least
200
scientists have signed a statement from
the cambridge working group
saying that it is gain of function well
it is not
and if you look at the grant and you
look at the progress reports
it has not gained a function despite the
fact
that people tweet that so you're trying
to figure out how to report sending
money to the wuhan virology institute
we do not send money now to do one hun
sending money we did under your tutelage
we were sending it through eco health it
was a sub agency
and a sub grant do you support the money
from nih that was going to the wuhan
institute
let me explain to you why that was done
the saws cov1 originated
in bats in china it would have been
irresponsible of us if we did not
investigate the bat viruses
and the serology to see who might have
been or perhaps it would be in china
to send it to the child so dr fauci was
totally ready for that and rand paul
had to then scale back the question you
might have noticed okay okay okay
it wasn't that type of research but in
this particular case but do you support
sending any money uh to the wuhan
institute of virology and fauci says we
do not
and rand paul says well okay yeah but we
did and maybe
uh well the situation was related to
sars
kovi one and of course we would fund
research where it originated that's an
important thing to understand
uh we were we were looking at sars kovi
one and we were looking at it where it
originated it makes sense to do that why
wouldn't we be doing that
okay so then they move on but rand paul
keeps pushing
at dr fauci stuff that is simply not
true
and fauci just keeps beating it off rand
paul goes back again to gain a function
research and voucher again has to beat
it but beat it back
absolutely in china possible to send it
to the chinese government that we may
not be able to trust with this
knowledge and with this uh incredibly
dangerous viruses
government scientists like yourself who
favor gain of function reason
i don't favor gain of function research
in china
naturally that are not correct
government defenders of gain of function
such as yourself
rand paul just won't be deterred right
uh and and this is not it
rand paul keeps going it starts to get
painful look at this
in the u.s we have 11 labs doing it and
you have allowed it here we have a
committee to do it but the committee is
granted every exemption
you're you're fooling with mother nature
here you're allowing super viruses to be
created
with a 15 mortality it's very dangerous
think it was a huge mistake to share
this with china and it's a huge mistake
to allow this to continue in the united
states
and we should be very careful to
investigate where this virus came from
i fully agree that you should
investigate where the virus came from
but again we have not funded gain of
function
research on this virus in the wuhan
institute of virology
no matter parsing words your part there
was research
there was research done with dr she and
dr barrick they have collaborated on
gain of function research
where they enhanced the sars virus to
infect
human airway cells and they did it by
merging a new spike protein on it
that is gain of function that was joint
research between the wuhan
institute and dr barrick you can't deny
it
senator paul your time time has expired
dr fatchi i will let you respond to that
when
we need to move on excuse me
i will allow you to respond to that and
then we'll move on yeah i mean i just
wanted to say
we i i don't know how many times i can
say it madam chair
we did not fund gain of function
research to be conducted in the wuhan
institute
of virology thank you you almost don't
really need dr fauci there and this is a
typical
uh what sometimes the term grandstanding
is thrown around for what happens
in these senate hearings and one way
that i identify grandstanding
is that even without the the the guest
or the witness or the person giving
testimony
you almost don't need them for the
senator to just keep doing what they're
what they do and saying what they say
they are going to say their peace
regardless
of what the witness contributes and rand
paul is just reading this stuff
regardless of what dr fauci says
and then lastly and this is really
important because of what it points to
senator tina smith who's a democrat from
minnesota
points out that line of questioning from
rand paul
when rand paul does that uh
it increases vaccine hesitancy take a
listen to this
thank you chair murray and uh thank you
so much to our
uh panelists for being here today um
i wanna just following up on that
exchange
uh just ask dr fauci a question dr fauci
what is the impact of
conspiracy theories peddled by senator
rand paul and others
on americans willingness to up to take
this vaccine
a vaccine that by all accounts is
remarkable for its safety and efficacy
well conspiracy theories certainly are
not helpful in what we're trying to do i
guess i can say that with some degree of
confidence
well i would agree and i think and
that's exactly right dr
fauci is being extremely careful and
reserved in his language i get that
but this is a major problem when you
start to see these lines of questioning
particularly from senators like rand
paul who have such
wacky basis bases of support can we
trust
anything can we trust what science knows
about the origins of the virus can we
trust
what anybody tells us about vaccines or
the seriousness of the disease
about the need to get vaccinated about
anything and
dr fauci just doing everything he can
to try to resist these continued
propaganda efforts from people like rand
paul
and it is not merely an annoyance
because you and i know that if he were
not dealing with this
and if he had not been dealing with this
stuff for the last year plus
dr fauci could have done so much more by
focusing his energy elsewhere but
you have to fight this stuff off uh it's
also that
it gets this these narratives in to
people's minds
and then they don't get vaccinated or
they don't wear masks where they should
or whatever the case may be so
there's a real world impact here for
rand paul maybe it is performative
theater i don't know i don't really know
what's in rand paul
rand paul's head but it has a
destructive real world impact
this is super super interesting and
uh or at least i found it so um there
was a
so there's a mayoral race in new york
city we're going to talk on the bonus
show today a little bit about andrew
yang's recent
twitter controversy andrew yang is a
candidate in the new york city mayoral
race
recently the new york times editorial
board interviewed
each of the candidates and this is
something that many newspapers do for
presidential races or sometimes senate
or whatever the case may be
with the mayoral race the new york times
interviews the candidates
and they asked the candidates do you
know the median
sales price for a home in brooklyn okay
now i used to live in brooklyn
and at the time when i last lived there
which was i guess
uh when was i last in in that
neighborhood in 2015
if at the time you had asked me the
median home price i think i would have
said 550
000 based on my understanding of of home
prices
there and two of the candidates uh were
asked about this
sean donovan and raymond maguire and
they were
so far off that it's almost like
do you have any idea what's going on in
the city
sean donovan uh said i don't know
for sure i would guess around 100
000 which you know when i see that i
wonder
if you're that out of touch which with
what's going on with home prices in
brooklyn
what else that's fundamental to the new
york city experience right now
do you have no idea about and then
raymond mcguire who's an investment
banker and former citigroup executive
was very similar he said
it's probably between 80 and 90 000
if not higher now i'm no real estate
expert
you know i i'm involved in a number of
properties in different parts of the
country and i have
you know sort of like a passing
knowledge of the fact that uh in
in east coast cities and and west coast
cities
uh properties are really expensive then
you have sort of secondary cities like
um you know austin and asheville where
property values are
going up but there's still quite a bit
less and then you've got rural you know
i have like a passing sense of it
um how on earth do you get to 80 90 or
100
000 median home price in brooklyn now
later one of the candidates said well i
thought you meant
assessed value it still doesn't make any
sense eric adams who's the brooklyn
borough president said he thought the
number was 550
that's the number i would have guessed
back in 2015
maya wiley former counsel to bill de
blasio guessed 1.8 million
and andrew yang uh correctly guessed 900
000
it's that that that's basically right
where we are so
how much do you think this is relevant
in thinking about whether a candidate
can properly manage a city from the
standpoint of
if you so misunderstand something as
fundamental as cost of living
if you underestimate by eight ninths
the cost of a median home in brooklyn
what else are you going to be unable to
sort of
empathize with or understand to me it
does seem
like a real problem now uh i this by the
way i don't know how many of you have
seen
bill gates was interviewed by ellen
degeneres a couple of years ago and they
did a sort of similar thing where ellen
asked bill gates you know what do you
think milk costs or whatever and bill
gates had like no idea there was like
some little frozen food thing and bill
gates
thought it cost 20 bucks when it's like
you know if if that thing cost 20 bucks
then
you know it just didn't didn't make any
sense is this relevant i think it is
relevant i kind of did a self-test
where um i uh wrote down
what do i think gasoline the average
home in miami
a gallon of milk bread and a gallon of
eggs cost just to see if i had
some sense of the sort of like national
numbers so for gasoline i guess
three dollars and i haven't gotten gas
for a while i've had an electric car
for for some time now and gasoline right
now is at 301
nationally so that's just like a random
guess
i seem sort of clued into that average
house in miami which is a market i
sort of know but not intimately i guess
the median home price in miami is 350
000
real number is 398 thousand so i'm sort
of testing
whether if you're at all connected to
what's going on
in the country you would be in the
ballpark and the more i was guessing
these numbers the more i think
guessing a hundred thousand for a
brooklyn median home price if you're
running for mayor
is a major red flag average price of a
gallon of milk now i did struggle with
this
because first of all i never buy a
gallon and i know when you buy less
the price per per per ounce goes up i
also admittedly i get hipster milk
i get like the pasture raised organic i
pay like five bucks for a half gallon
i guessed for a gallon of organic milk
it's five dollars it's actually four
um and uh similarly with eggs ever since
reading michael pollan's books about
this
i've decided the extra couple bucks for
pastured
eggs and pastured milk i've just decided
it's worth it i don't consume
so much that it really makes a big
difference so like with eggs i'm getting
those like bright orange yolk eggs or
whatever
it's like six bucks a dozen so i guessed
for like your basic
cage free eggs it's probably something
like three dollars and it turns out it's
266 and then lastly for bread
i struggled with bread because like you
know the difference between a loaf of
processed wonder bread
and artisanal seed bread or whatever
it seems like it's the difference
between a dollar and eight dollars i
don't know
uh i guess three dollars the official
rate for bread is 2.50
so like how relevant is this stuff if
you're listening to a candidate
um say that they hear uh they hear you
about the issues in your city
they believe they can fix some of those
issues they want to bring this and they
want to bring that
and then you ask them what do you think
the medium home value is when it's 900
000 and they say 80 grand that seems to
me like a material concern
and i'm curious to hear from you whether
you agree
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at dpakman we will take a
quick break
and we have so much more upcoming
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him paul boyer is an arizona
state senator who originally was
supportive of the arizona recount of the
2020 election which we recently
discussed which is looking at things
like
bamboo fibers on ballots in maricopa
county paul boyer was supportive of that
originally and that very same state
senator now
says he regrets his support of that
movement and that it quote makes
us look like idiots it's i guess like a
moment of clarity
in a sea of absurdity in arizona
and of course he's absolutely correct
but really only at the micro level and
what i mean by that is that
yes the individuals who supported this
nonsense and i mean josh hawley in the
u.s
senate people like paul boyer in the
arizona state senate the whole lot of
them
they do look like idiots he's right
about that
but the problem is that we as a country
look like idiots internationally
globally
because of these people now the full
quote from senator paul boyer
is it makes us look like idiots i didn't
think it would be this ridiculous
it's embarrassing to be a state senator
at this point
now it's all great paul boyer came to
realize this he's now saying it's a bad
idea okay
but you can't simply disown the entire
movement that you started
simply because it imploded in shame and
what i mean by that is
that paul boyer is reacting to the
outcome of this movement
imagine if somehow i mean it would have
been a tragedy nationally but imagine if
they had found a way a bogus way
to change the outcome of a state where
they figured out a way wow even though
biden won arizona
they figure out some way to flip it to
donald trump or imagine if they had been
able to do it in enough states
to actually flip the election from joe
biden to donald trump
he wouldn't be saying that we looked
like idiots he'd be saying we did
something heroic
even though the truth in either case
is that joe biden won and being able to
flip the results or even trying to do so
is a trash garbage movement he's trying
to disown it now
because it failed and because it didn't
go anywhere
and because it's become this national
and global laughing stock and so he
wants to wash his hands of it now
because it failed to achieve excuse me
what he wanted it to achieve at least
initially
and at some point they need to accept
that they are number one
wrong on the facts and number two
they are idiots because they fell for it
it's not just we
ended up looking like idiots and what's
unsaid is in part because this failed to
do anything
it was idiotic to fall for this from the
beginning
and you know looking at bamboo fibers
yet another conspiracy theory so the
point here is
great it's always great when someone
realizes the error of their ways
or of their beliefs and they come to
correct that
that's one of the reasons why science as
a process
is so valuable because it contains an
error correcting mechanism and fixing
mistakes or finding that someone
uh did something wrong believed
something wrong
it's rewarded in science at least it
should be when things go
correctly but it's not you're instantly
rehabilitated
because one time much too late 170
percent of republicans
still believe to this day that donald
trump actually won the election and joe
biden is not the legitimate president
now you say oh we look like idiots oh
great wow you're back
you're great you're great now you
stumbled into a fact among a sea of
trash propaganda
and now you want a cookie and this is
you know it's it's it's an important
analysis also in the context of the liz
cheney thing
the republican party are a bunch of
hypocrites when they say they're against
canceling people
and liz cheney says hey guys trump lost
and what he's doing is dangerous and
what he did is dangerous
you're canceled yes they're hypocrites
liz cheney is correct
that we have a process and the process
worked and we had an election and we
know the results
she's right about that that's it she
doesn't become a progressive hero
she is not on the left we disagree about
just about everything
um and that's an important thing to
remember when we look at these maya
culpas and we look at these
uh i mean not a term i use but come to
jesus moments
um do something now to deal with the
systemic fiasco
that you as a part of the republican
party this applies to state senator paul
boyer
it applies to liz cheney it applies to
all of them do something that deals with
the systemic issues
and then maybe i would find myself
having more praise for you
we have um the resurgence of the matt
gates story
now many of you wrote to me
two weeks ago last week maybe even three
weeks ago
saying david what on earth happened to
that matt gates investigation we learned
that congr republican congressman from
florida matt gates
has been under investigation possibly
for child sex trafficking
he may have paid underage girls for sex
he may have actually paid to uh
transit them from one state to another
there's all this stuff blowing up
uh with matt gates but then the story
just kind of disappeared
and my view two weeks ago my view last
week was it's going to come back there
have been distractions because of other
things that have been going on
the joe biden address to a joint session
of congress etc etc all of these other
things
the story is now coming back and we are
now learning that federal investigators
as reported by the week
are pushing for the cooperation of two
key witnesses
in investigating matthew gates including
an ex-girlfriend of matt gates when the
investigators
talk to the ex-girlfriend it's rarely
good
if the ex-girlfriend cooperates it's
very
very bad for matt gates and
investigators are looking for
cooperation from an ex-girlfriend
who is actually an intern on capitol
hill
uh i don't think many of us would be
shocked by that and they are also
looking for formal cooperation from that
joel greenberg he's the former county
tax collector in florida
who we now have reason to believe
because of a letter he wrote
that greenberg himself introduced matt
gates to
underage girls this is all
potentially disastrous for matt gates
the investigation
in part is over whether gates had sex
with a 17 year old girl
and violated federal sex trafficking
laws
he's denied wrongdoing the denials are
essentially meaningless at this point
and the former girlfriend that
investigators are seeking cooperation
from
reportedly joined gates in 2018
on a trip to the bahamas which has
become a big focus of the investigation
she was quote involved in some financial
transactions that the fbi has obtained
and is quote believed to have knowledge
of drug use
and arrangements with women this is
potentially
very bad for matt gates we expected
that as things settled back down in the
u.s we would get back to the gates story
and indeed the news is starting to flow
on that and consider the insanity
to go back to our story about the
cancellation of republican congresswoman
liz cheney
who's been voted out of her
leadership role because she said hey
guys trump lost
essentially look at how the republican
party
has been almost silent on the gates
fiasco
but are overly zealous to punish liz
cheney merely for saying
yeah biden one consider that incredible
hypocrisy and
it's not just that they claim to be
against cancel culture
but they regularly try to cancel people
they also regularly
regularly are going after the wrong
people and the gates cheney thing
is exhibit a and um
whether matt gates will be charged we
still don't know there's a lot of
unknowns here
but it is not looking particularly good
we have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day
the number is 2192 david p here is a
really interesting voicemail
about this continued topic of the
anti-cancer culture republicans
canceling one of their own not a very
big tent
is what it's seeming like take a listen
to this hey dave
you know the the right that has a very
large tent that doesn't cancel anybody
like extreme people like lauren bobert
and matt gates they won't be cancelled
because they don't believe in castle
culture
they want to encompass all sorts of
different voices however
after canceling liz cheney from the
canceled culture
right you have a question dave do you
think liz cheney can come back twice as
strong
and cancel the crap out of the
republican party
what is she going to do i don't think
she's going to go quietly
seriously is she going to become a
democrat no she's very conservative
right but what can she do to get them
back i have a hunch we have not seen
the last of liz cheney i'm actually
rooting for her now trello and brother
yeah i agree that liz cheney won't go
quietly but i'm skeptical that there's
much she can do and the reason i say
that is
the party of the republican party is
still completely under the control of
trump and trumpism
in fact the cancellation of liz cheney
is further evidence of that we've been
wondering will they go pro-trump or
anti-trump going into 2022
will they go more in the direction of
cheney and romney or are they going to
go more in the direction of
beau bert marjorie taylor green madison
cawthorne louis gomer jim jordan
elise stefanik etc and the cancellation
of bliss cheney to me is evidence that
they're going with the trump side
uh 70 of the voters still believe trump
actually won
uh two-thirds of the republican voters
that's 70 of republican voters
two-thirds of republican voters claimed
they'd follow trump to another party
they are choosing to get rid of liz
cheney for something
from leadership she's still in the house
for something
as seemingly uncontroversial as what
should be uncontroversial of just saying
oh the election results are the results
and trump lost
shouldn't be even uh shouldn't even be
anything
um and yet she is losing her leadership
role because of that so
while i agree that liz cheney does not
seem like the type
to just go quietly uh i am un
unsure about what she actually will be
able to do substantively because this
party seems to have gone
fully in with trump for 2022 as of what
we're seeing for the for the uh
in the immediate if you see it
differently let me know but that's the
way it's looking
uh to me we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today a homeless man
has been awarded a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars as a judge has
tossed out st louis county
anti-panhandling ordinances
this is very interesting and the
precedent that it sets
could be meaningful and long-lasting in
terms of how we criminalize
homelessness in many parts of the
country number two
a judge has dismissed the nra bankruptcy
case
making it more likely the nra may be
dissolved
uh cautious optimism there and we will
also talk about
new york city mayoral candidate andrew
yang
now in hot water with a bunch of
different people
over a tweet he sent about the
israeli-palestinian conflict
followed by a letter he put out this
morning
we'll explain all of it and discuss the
implications
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show how do you get the bonus show
a lot of people are wondering and the
answer remains
very simple sign up at joinpakman.com
that's it
it's cheap it's quick it's easy you
support the show
and if you would like a discount off of
that membership to hear our
takes on all of these extra stories use
the coupon code better21
you save big you get 100 of the benefits
at a major discount join pacman.com
we'll see everybody on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try
it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman